gran parte del vecindario sigue
sumergido bajo el agua mientras
continúan las lluvias intermitentes
algunas personas tuvieron que salir
corriendo de sus casas en plena noche la
gente estaba dormida y cuando nos dimos
cuenta de que el agua había invadido la
casa solo tuvimos tiempo de sacarlas
afortunadamente no hubo víctimas
mortales aquí tenemos casi 1.8 metros de
agua en algunas casas
entre ciudades unas doscientas personas
fueron rescatadas en botes las fuertes
corrientes del río caura haya crecido
dificultaron las operaciones de rescate
con este volumen de agua incluso
desplazarse con motos de agua es difícil
es difícil reducir los riesgos para el
conductor o la víctima que está siendo
rescatada
las inundaciones se han mantenido de
forma intermitente durante semanas
provocando que el gobernador del estado
califique lo sucedido como el peor
desastre de la historia de bahía las
fuertes precipitaciones se produjeron
después de una larga sequía afectando a
los medios de subsistencia en el estado
brasilero de 15 millones de habitantes
la situación se agravó durante las
navidades después de de presa se dieran
lo que motivó a los ciudadanos a buscar
terrenos más altos mientras 72
municipios de bahía se encuentran bajo
el estado de emergencia los medios
locales afirman que las autoridades
están vigilando otras 10 presas para
detectar cualquier indicio de nuevos
derrumbes